very quickly you mentioned Thor mostly
so we can show this picture sure why
don't you be embarrassed
a lot of dieting but also apparently is
this true the people this is odd so
people come up to you and they want you
to tell a specific joke although just
come and tell me for a joke go do you
know the joke about the Thor spends a
night with this woman and the next
morning he says I have to tell you who I
am you know I'm Thor she says you're
Thor I can have the walk
[Applause]
what were you in prison Chris
[Laughter]
well they go to prison so we know it's
researching a film and we had to go in
and basically see what the inside of a
prison look like and speak with
prisoners who are willing to talk to us
and um and I walked in and I remember
thinking and I had but ponytail long
blonde hair and I had a hat on and the
wardens little he knows where this is
going
and the warden said you can't wear your
hat and so on and I said ok no worries
nothing [__] they're gonna Know Who I am
than Athan if they don't get Thor in
here they're not gonna watch movies and
I'd never been to prison so assume that
and the moment I started walking through
the cells and it's like each block of
this thing and it's all just kind of it
you know cell upon cell and so on and I
just start getting heckled and it's like
you blend in and you know research and
just getting a heckled left and right
about you know come spend some time in
my shell baby hey guys that was it
wasn't a whole research more just kind
of you've made the choice to bring your
children back to Australia yeah yeah so
with the all born in America and then
you brought them back now my daughter
was born here in London actually yep and
then the boys are born in America
and we moved back to Australia and now
you've posted pictures online and it
makes me think was bringing your
children back there that wise like you
pick that's your house yeah that is
that's yeah one of the bedrooms here is
it one of the children's bedrooms
occasionally yeah since that snake lives
there and then you're like is that in
your house it is yeah yeah
they better than paparazzi though those
animals okay I would take paparazzi over
the spider and the snake yeah you know
that snake the the what you don't say
we'd had a couple of drinks that night
when we discovered that snake in the
bedroom and we found the snake and
and I'm lost and again what is it and
someone's like it's a brown snake which
can kill you you know very quickly
someone's like now it's a tree python
it's something else is this and I just
launched into like action mode grabbed
it by the tail picked it up anyone
starts freaking out and it starts to
kind of coil itself back up toward me
which is getting ready to strike and I'm
everything at what the hell am i doing
so I just kind of threw the snake back
into the bedroom the door we don't go in
that bedroom anymore we have a little
mobile with stars and Suns on it there
another addition to the cast our good
friend Chris Hemsworth I think I've got
a picture of Chris Hemsworth it's I just
at a certain point I thought I have
never rooted for someone maybe to be
just an unbelievable jerk I just needed
something to be wrong with him and there
was nothing for the four of you you must
be annoying cuz you got to think we're
very funny and here's this hunk he's
annoyingly funny
did you bring writers or something funny
like a guy that had to fight his way off
the playground his whole life and he had
to be funny so he didn't get his ass
kicked very strange and at one point he
started I don't know we were talking
about music we're playing something and
I said what song you tie him up and he
started singing and I did not mean to
but very it was deep and guttural object
you shut up
he started to sound like a songbird just
be quiet
I don't help people to shut up but I was
like I said can you sing and he's like
walking carry a tune I was like
something I'm gonna pretend you're a
terrible singer so I know you're human
I bet he doesn't even have boogers he
does have boogers they taste like corn
flakes crispy crispy like that too you
spent too long now this is wrong you
can't put this long discussing someone
on his show we were sad when he left we
he got a cake it was a lot honey it'll
get fat my ass he was eating cake he got
more chiseled but weirdly I didn't have
any cake and when he was in his butt I
had gained like 6 months
[Music]
you